字幕: Chie Kosuga
校正: Kazunori Akashi
『ミクロの決死圏』
ご覧になられた方いらっしゃいますでしょうか
ありがとうございます
だいぶご年配圏というところでしょうか
（笑）
私もこれずいぶん昔に見た映画なんですが
脳血栓ができてしまった科学者を救うという
そういうストーリーです
５人の医療チームが集められ
なぜだか潜水艇に乗り込みます
そこで最先端の科学技術を使って
ミニチュア化されて血管内に送り込まれる
もちろんストーリー上
いろんなトラブルがあるんですが
なんとか その血栓を力を合わせて破壊して
で ついにその科学者を救うというものです
もちろんこれは
サイエンティフィック・フィクション—
SFの中の話です
でもこんな世の中というのが
いずれ訪れるんでしょうか？
実は我々の身の回りには
SFで描かれた技術というのが
いくつも現実化したものがあります
みなさんの携帯電話とか
あるいはタブレットコンピューター
あとドローン
これはもう 2、30年前までは
完全に夢の技術でした
ある心理学者はこのように述べています
SFなどのフィクションは
我々に思考実験の機会を与えている
思考実験というのは本当に頭の中で行う
全くお金のかからない実験のことです
で 私もこのような
ミニチュアの世界というのを長年夢見てきて
頭の中で空想してきた
そんな科学者の一人でもあります
改めてそのミニチュアの世界というのを
思い起こさせたのが
こちらは『シンギュラリティは近い』という
レイ・カーツワイルという
未来学者がいらっしゃるんですが
2005年に発表した
ノンフィクション書籍です
その中にこんな一節があります
2020年 我々は赤血球
あるいはそれ以下のサイズの
ロボットを開発しているだろうというものです
これはあの映画を
思い起こさせるものでもありました
今日はあの映画の封切りから
50年経っていますけども
どこまでそのロボットが開発されてきたのか
そんなロボットの話を私の研究も交えながら
皆さんに紹介したいというふうに思います
そもそもロボットとは何でしょうか
そのロボットをよく見ていくと
３つの要素が必要だと
いうことに気づかされます
ひとつは周りをセンスするようなセンサー
それからその情報を処理するプロセッサー
さらにそのプロセッサーからの指示を受けて
動きへと変換するためのモーター
すなわちロボットとはこの３つの要素を備えた
システムだというふうに考えることができます
しかしあの映画や書籍に出てくる
ロボットというのは桁違いに小さいです
どれくらい小さいのか
身のまわりにあるロボットと比較してみると
それがよくわかります
赤血球よりも少し大きくて
私たちの髪の毛の直径よりも少し小さい
といったようなサイズ感になります
従来の方法論では そんな小さいロボットは
おそらく作れない
どうしたらいいのか
その鍵を握るのが
先程ロボットの３要素を挙げましたが
そのうちのひとつ
モーターにあると我々は考えました
でもモーターなんてそんな小さいものを
作る技術 あるんでしょうか
私は学生時代に少しだけ
バイオテクノロジーというのを
かじったことがありました
この技術を足掛かりにしてみることにしました
特に注目しましたのが生体の中で
いろんな物質の運搬に関わっている
タンパク質からなる分子機械というもので
この分子機械は体の中に豊富にある
ATPという化合物を分解することで
エネルギーを得ることができます
ですので この生体分子機械を
先程の分子ロボットの
いわゆるエンジンというふうにしてしまえば
生体内任務において
エネルギーの心配がなくなる—
これがその発想の原点です
ちなみに先ほどの潜水艇ですが
エネルギーは原子力でした
小さいと大丈夫なんでしょうかね
（笑）
で 早速 研究室の学生とともに
このモーターの開発を進めます
けれどもそれは困難の連続でした
と申しますのも
つい先程バイオテクノロジーに
精通しているというふうに申し上げましたが
実は若干 話を盛っていました
（笑）
座学程度の 実は知識しかなくて
しかも学生の前で申し上げるのは
かなりはばかられるんですが
その講義の大半は睡眠学習にあてていたと
（笑）
まあけれどもそんな無知を
ひけらかすわけにもいかないということで
まあコソコソと論文読んだり
あるいは書籍を読んだりして
ああでもないこうでもないを繰り返し
ようやくその分子機械を
実験室内で動かせるようになってきたんです
これはその水中の中で動いている
モーターの様子です
いかがでしょうか
私にとってみたら最高の癒し系動画です
（笑）
サイズは大体10マイクロメートル
これは赤血球の直径に相当します
このようにしてモーターというものを
手に入れることができるようになったんですが
まだロボットに必要な２つの要素
プロセッサーと あとセンサーに関する
アイディアというのは
まだ浮かんでおりませんでした
そのプロセッサーの開発に関わる出会いが
ある講演会でありました
葛谷博士はアメリカで
DNAナノテクノロジーというものを学んで
帰国した直後でした
彼の講演を聞いて
これは使えると直感的に思いました
DNAがです
DNAは生体の中では遺伝子情報の伝達
あるいは保存といった役割をしておりますが
ATGCという暗号に基づく
高度な認識能というのを有しています
この認識能を活用して デジタルデータの保存
あるいは数学的な問題さえ解けてしまうような
そういう分子コンピューターというのが
開発されている そういう時代でもありました
早速 札幌にあるラボに戻って
共同研究をスタートさせます
けれどもまあ
そううまくいくわけではありませんでした
と申しますのも まず先ほどのモーターに
このDNAを乗せてしまうと
途端に動かなくなってしまいます
けれどもせっかく動き始めた共同研究ですので
１年近く頑張りました
でも結果はほとんど変わりませんでした
これは中でも一番いい
組み合わせの状態のものなんですが
のたうち回ってるだけです
ただ もう一回奮起する
契機というのが訪れます
この分子ロボットというのをもう少し真面目に
考えてみようという趣旨の研究会が発足し
我々２人もそのメンバーとして
加わることになります
ただ 同じ過ちを繰り返すわけにはいかない
どうしたものか
分子コンピューティングの世界では非常に
長くて複雑なDNAが好んで用いられます
私たちもそんなDNAを使おうとしていました
まずそれをやめて 数千にまで及ぶDNAを
まず数十にまで落とすことにしました
そして複雑な配列も一切やめて
３つの単純な繰り返しからなる配列を
使うことにしました
この発想の転換が上手くいきました
DNAを搭載したモーターがするすると
動き始めてくれるようになったんです
このとき だいぶテンションも
上がっておりましたので
思わず赤と緑でカラーリングまで
してしまっています
（笑）
けれどもこの分子に
どんなプログラムを書き込めばいいのか
まだまだ悩みは尽きません
そもそもこれ分子です
１分子では あまりに非力すぎやしないかと
あの映画の中でも
力を合わせて任務遂行を果たす
このような共同作業というのは
自然界の中では普遍的に
見られる現象でもあります
例えば鳥は群れることによって
信じられないぐらい遠くの越冬地まで
飛んで行くことができますし
魚は群れの形態を変えることによって
敵の目を欺きます
さらにアリも同様に群れることで
１個体で運べなかったような
大きな荷物も運びます
中には運ばれているのもいるようですが
（笑）
このようにして「群れる」ということで
今までできなかったことが
どんどんどんどん できるようになってきます
私たちもこの群れの形成 乖離を
指示するプログラムを
先程の分子のシステムに
書き込むことにしました
このアイディアは私の留学先でもあった
ニューヨーク コロンビア大学の
ヘス博士とともに
長年 取り組んできた課題でもあります
まずDNAからできた情報を
先程の分子システムに受け渡します
するとそれを認識して
まるで手を取り合うようにして
寄り添い始めるというのが
基本的なアイディアになっています
でも あれほどまで
単純化してしまったプロセッサーが
果たして機能してくれるかどうか
まだ不安は残っていました
そこでまず先程 丁寧に色分けした
２種類のフィラメントを
ある場所に集めていきます
すると この際にはまだ
お互い混信つまり干渉しているような
様子は見られませんでした
ここで恐る恐る
「群れ」を作る指示が入ったDNAを
ピペッターという装置を使って
１滴ほど垂らしてみることにします
こちらはそのピペッターの図になります
ちなみにこちらの顕微鏡は
普段は我々が愛用しているものでもあります
するとどうでしょうか
先程の分子がみるみるうちに集まり始めてきて
やがて巨大な群れを作り始めたんです
（拍手）
これは先程は赤と緑で色分けした
分子が混じり合うことによって
黄色い集合体を作っています
またここに乖離を指示するDNAを
もう１滴垂らしてみると
今度は群れが離散していきます
これは入れた直後です
一部拡大してみますと 黄色い群れから
先程の緑と赤の分子が
出てきている様子がわかります
さらに興味深いことにこの分子の構造を
少しチューニングすることによって
群れの形態も大きく変えられると
いうことがわかりました
こちらでは先程の魚の群れのように
渦を巻いて回転しています
（拍手）
もちろん ここにも同じように
DNAの情報を滴下してやると
約300体近い数ですかね
飛び出てきます
少し気持ち悪い映像かもしれませんが
（笑）
またこの分子の群れには 異なる複数の
指令を出すことも可能だということが
最近の研究からわかってきました
例えば 黄色い群れを作りなさい
そしてその場で回転しなさい
もうひとつは緑色の群れを作り
あたりを探索しなさい
という情報を与えてみました
どうでしょうか
そのように従ってくれているように
見えませんか
（笑）
まだ周りが気になるのか
黄色の群れを見に行く緑の群れというのが
いたるところで見られます
少し触ってみては また探索に出かけると
いったような塩梅でしょうか
さて このようにして文字どおり
私たちの分子ロボットプロジェクトというのが
走り始めたわけであります
しかしまだ もうひとつ部品が足りません
センサーです
幸運なことに先程の研究会で
センサーの開発をしていた
浅沼博士との出会いがありました
ある化合物をDNAの中に入れると
それを光でスイッチングできるというものです
例えば黄色い光を当てると
プロセッサーがオンとなり
紫色の光を当てるとオフとなる
といったような塩梅です
実際どうでしょうか
黄色い光を当ててみますと
先程の分子が集まってきて
まるでアメーバのような群れを作ります
それからここに紫色の光
ちょうどこんな感じの光でしょうかね
を当ててみますと 群れが離散してまいります
この光に対する応答性というのは
群れの形態によらないということも
最近わかってきました
こちらは回転している群れですが
こちらも同じように光を当てると
離散が始まります
ちょうどこれは我々の作った分子ロボットの
視覚 目に相当するというふうに考えられます
でも このようにして作り上げた
モーターとプロセッサー センサーを搭載した
いわば分子ロボットの原型に
何ができるでしょうか
最後に簡単な
デモンストレーションをご紹介して
私の話を締めくくりたいと思います
こちらでは角砂糖に見立てたある結晶を
先程の分子ロボットの群れに放り投げてみます
するとそれをしっかりと捕捉して
運んでいく様子というのが捉えられています
（拍手）
でも皆さんにお伝えしたいのは
これは１個体ではできなかったんです
群れることによって初めて
できるようになった芸当でもありました
私たちの分子ロボット
まだまだできることは限られています
でもどうでしょうか
将来もっといろんな機能や構造を持った
分子ロボットが開発され
そしてそれが集団となれば
無限の力を発揮できるかもしれません
私自身も同様にできることは
極めて限られています
今日お話しした分子ロボットの話も
多くの研究者の協力があって
初めて実現されたものです
まだまだ先のことになるかもしれませんが
いつしかみんなで協力して
あの映画の世界というのを
実現したいと思っています
そして我々人類が直面する課題を
少しでもいいから解決していきたいというのが
私たちの夢でもあります
力を合わせれば可能性は無限大
どうもありがとうございました
（拍手）